foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists we've got malabama
here today hi everybody C.K Coleman
Jingle Bell Rock
we got the rest of our team in the
studio as well coming up today on this
free public minimal episode we're
talking to a listener about the best
gift
and no we're not even talking about
Christmas gifts we're talking about the
best gift we also have an outstanding
lightning round segment a live stream
question and a listener tip for you you
can check out the full three hour
maximal edition it's a whole minimalist
celebration on episode 371 that private
podcast episode is out right now at
patreon.com
the minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because say it with
me y'all
advertisements suck oh let's start with
our callers if you have a question or
comment for our show give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo it's
a podcast at the minimalists.com our
first question today is from Christina
Christina from Philadelphia here I was
diagnosed with Stage 2B triple negative
breast cancer last April at the age of
32 and spent the last year going through
chemo multiple surgeries and radiation
the time of diagnosis I was in the
absolute best shape of my life had just
become debt free and was living an
intentional minimalist life I was so
thankful to receive a clear pathology
report and I'm currently in remission
but still navigating through the trauma
of the past year
what are some practices you can
Implement to recover from the severely
traumatic life-altering experiences that
disease brings and find Joy again when
the idea of death is still so palpable
we're going to talk about disease quite
a bit later on we just did an episode on
chronic illness and you can go back and
check that out obviously but I'm going
to give a completely different answer
for this question but later in the
private podcast I do want to talk to you
all about
unconventional thoughts on disease and
we'll save that for for the private
podcast but there's something really
beautiful Christina about what you're
saying here is you're beginning to
realize that a clean slate is
the best gift we've all been given a
clean slate at some point in time it's
it's really freeing in a way now earlier
during the intro on the the private
podcast we were talking about
Ryan's and my journey over the last well
30 something years but especially the
the last 12 years we started the
minimalists.com 12 years ago this month
and a lot has happened since then but
that new beginning for us really was a
clean slate it was it was wiping things
clean now what do I mean by that well
it's the expectations of the past
that one was a huge clean slate no
longer am I expected to be the director
of operations for this
telecommunications company
and that's really hard at first because
our identity gets really wrapped up in
what the things from our past even as
Christina said I was in the best shape
of my life well that's true for everyone
at some point everyone was in the best
shape of their life at some point me
right now at age 41 I'm currently in the
best shape of my adult life of my entire
life really because as a kid I was a
note my shape was round as a kid
you were a shape someone so you're in
shape
I was in a shape and oh shoot but what
I'll say is at some point though I'm
going to look in the mirror
and I'm gonna say huh what's wrong with
this mirror I like the mirrors from the
past better
now what am I what do I mean by this I
mean that at some point it all fades
yeah now it might be when you're 80
years old you know Jack LaLanne was
still in awesome shape when he was age
90 or whatever right but 90 year old
Jack LaLanne wasn't 30 year old Jack
LaLanne and so with time it all fades
anyway but the beauty of a clean slate
what it allows us to do is put things in
perspective I'm not carrying the past
with me anymore a few months ago we came
in here Mallory and Professor Sean and I
and Ryan was here as well and we used
the out in the open rule to declutter
our office space and we did it as part
of our photo tour that week on the
private podcast we brought literally all
of our stuff out and even as the
minimalists what happened we had too
many things things from the past all of
our things are always things from the
past by the way we never bring out
things from the future because we don't
have things from the future what a clean
slate does is it gets everything out in
the open so Christina I applaud you for
going through this I know how painful a
disease can be how painfully chronic
illness can be how painful inflammation
can be
but what has happened here is you've
brought everything out into the open
including your own expectations your own
desires for the future and there's
nothing wrong with those things but when
you bring it all in the open you finally
get to examine
everything that your life has been about
everything you've been striving for
everything you've been chasing
and you realize that many of the things
you were chasing you don't realize why
you were chasing and in fact the things
Ryan and I were chasing in the corporate
world we talked about this on the
private podcast intro the things we were
chasing the corporate world
man I was actually running in the wrong
direction
and I didn't have to run the other way I
didn't want to run away from the
corporate world but I did need to at
some point turn around and walk away
from it and that's what letting go is
all about yeah
I'm going to quote to you a lyric from a
song popularized by the great Nat King
Cole who said uh there was a boy certain
strange Enchanted boy they said he
traveled very far very far over land and
sea and then one day one magic day he
came my way and as we spoke of many
things fools and Kings this he said to
me the greatest joy that you'll ever
learn is just to love and be loved in
return
when our life is Afflicted with pain
particularly the kind of pain that you
shared with us today the kind of pain
that can't always be changed or treated
it's so important to remind ourselves
that there is nothing that can take away
our ability to make another human being
feel loved that we always have the
capacity to serve someone else to bless
someone else to help someone else and
relationships one of the things that you
know I heard the saying life is a
terminal illness and it comes for us all
and it's just a matter of when but what
that brings to us is an awareness that
man
when it all goes down the only thing
that matters is who I loved and who I
allowed to love to me who I allow to
love me and that's not just like some
moral position that's actually the
greatest soothing ailment to our pain to
those pains that we can't change it's
that knowledge that man
even with all that I'm going through and
all that I can't change
there's still someone out there who
feels seen and who feels heard because
of the life that I'm living and because
of the way that I'm giving and so when
you ask about ways to to deal with this
especially after the traumatic
experience has taken so many things away
I would say look for opportunities to
open your heart up to be available to
those who want to be there for you and
look for opportunities to be there for
people who might need you in spite of
the feelings of man inadequacy in spite
of the feelings of ah hurt and
frustration that might come up in your
life and make you feel like it's over
um
yeah ma'am how do I follow that
I knew I should have went next give me
Natalie Cole
right exactly
um you know you
Josh you're talking about that clean
slate and it made me realize like the
the what I did with that clean slate is
I got clear on my values and I started
re-prioritizing how I was spending my
time and yeah I never looked at it that
way but that's certainly
what minimalism did for me yeah it gave
me a clean slate
um and what a gift that is oh yeah it's
yeah and by the way it's really
terrifying at first right because you
have that clean slate and it's like
unlimited possibilities
and it is terrifying at first and I
noticed that with you Ryan when you
first started letting go
the and you have this clean slate in
front of you you start clinging to
things I mean the the easy example is
when I was trying to get rid of all
those 30 coffee mugs you had when you
were doing your packing party even those
it was difficult to let go of because
the Clean Slate of not having all of
that excess is kind of scary now with
Christina it's even more pronounced than
that because this is clean slate when oh
I could have died yeah and this is bonus
time now yeah absolutely no I'm so glad
to hear about your recovery Christina
that's awesome
um
her question made me think about when I
broke my back
and like I was asking the doctor I'm
like what do I do and he's like dude you
do nothing he's like you have to be in
bed for six weeks yes I'm like oh yeah I
guess that makes sense like no
stretching no he's like no man like you
need to lay in bed and heal like that's
what you need to do so
Christina I would say you don't really
need to do anything in particular
um and I think that's a pressure that we
put on ourselves
far too much where we feel like we have
to do something
you're talking about the difference
between healing and fixing yeah so often
we go how do I fix this
and yes if you have your truck breaks
down
it makes sense to fix it
but we're human beings and quite often
that clean slate makes room for the
healing yes the physical healing but
also that internal spiritual mental
psychological emotional healing that so
many I would argue almost all of us need
it makes room for the being part of
human being
you know uh back in the day I was
watching the Chicago Bulls the
jordan-led Bulls play against the
Portland Trailblazers and Bill Walton
was uh calling the game and the Portland
Trailblazers are just falling apart they
had control of the game and they're just
falling apart and one of the guys says
what's wrong with Portland right now and
Bill Walton says they're playing not to
lose you can't play not to lose and I
was like what does he mean they're
playing not to lose and what he meant by
that was there's a difference in the way
you approach the game when you're taking
the risk necessary to win than when
you're just being cautious and trying to
avoid the filling of losing is
inevitable and I think that's a good
metaphor for life as well there's a
difference in the energy that you bring
to the Game of Life when you live not to
die versus when you live to leave it all
on the table and sometimes things that
can make us feel vulnerable can put us
in a defense of mindset where we're just
cautious about everything and we start
to live not to die and that's when our
life is sucked out of us and what I
would say to all of us is
the the highest level to live at is when
death Catches Us in the middle of the
creative process because we weren't busy
running from death but we were busy
giving everything so that we could die
empty before it comes yeah
man I love what you said earlier about
uh something about like we're all
heading there you said something about
being terminal whatever your life it
reminded me of Childish Gambino's line
from uh Because the Internet uh he said
being born is a death sentence yeah and
I'm like man that is yeah that's that is
really profound yeah oh man um Mariah my
lovely wife gave me like the best advice
the other day so I hurt myself playing
frisbee golf yes it's possible 41 years
old it's possible to hurt yourself
playing frisbee golf to be fair it's
tackle frisbee golf full contact frisbee
golf no I just my
um my swing hey I was playing a little
bit too much and uh my throw uh I just
I'm not relaxed enough
which is funny because like you would
think it's all about the strength but
it's really about like being relaxed the
form the flick like it's it has nothing
to do with like tensing up but I was
like super tensing up because I always
play to win I hate losing
um Josh you can tell you he beats me at
ping pong all the time
um I used to give him a run for his
money but now he just slutters me it's
not even fun anymore
um but uh Mariah gave me this awesome
piece of advice uh she read a quote
somewhere she was like oh this quote
might apply to your frisbee golf and it
said something I'm paraphrasing here it
said something along the lines of uh
don't give a hundred percent give 85
because when you're giving a hundred
percent you are taking those risks and
you are pre you are putting too much
pressure on yourself and you actually
don't perform as well uh as if you just
gave 85 and that's what the Trailblazers
were doing they were giving it a hundred
percent not the way but that ended up
being their demise because yeah they
they could have just scaled back a
little bit but yeah it went for it yeah
Christine I'm going to send you a copy
of our book everything that remains Ryan
we wrote the first draft of this book a
decade ago and it's really a book about
creating that clean slate in our own
lives and what a gift that was and also
how terrifying that was yes we were two
suit and tie corporate guys walking away
from the corporate world it's probably
my favorite book that we've ever
published and I really enjoy the way
that it is formatted so it's 200 and
some pages but it's written from my
perspective but every page Ryan
interrupts me it's rather memetic of our
relationship and so I don't ever
interrupt them
Ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your questions from Tick
Tock yes indeed you can follow the
minimalists on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalists
during the lightning round this is where
we each have 60 seconds to answer your
questions well the short shareable less
than 140 character response we put the
text to these minimal maxims in the show
notes over at the minimalists.com
podcast so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you
like it looks like Shawna has a question
for us I have loved ones that actively
try to discourage my minimalist
lifestyle because it makes them
uncomfortable and insecure how do we
continue to love our friends and family
when they act like this professor Sean
put 60 seconds on the clock for our good
friend Ryan Nicodemus oh am I going
first Let's Do It Let's Do It um well
one thing I'll say before I get my fifth
answer
um I'm reading this uh Ryan holiday book
it's like the life of Stokes I'm sure
you've read it yeah
um I forget who it was uh but they one
of the Stokes basically said when you
when you're reputation starts to build
people will attack it from all angles
and that's what's happening here so
here's here's my epithy answer for you
Shauna
compassion is the gateway to
understanding yes so in order to receive
passion you have to show compassion
and sometimes you've got to be the
bigger person to step up and show that
compassion I'm not saying that you know
uh this is the rule 100 of the time but
maybe here it might be it might be uh a
thing that you can try Shauna because if
you can show your family that you truly
care about them you can show them
compassion about their uh desires their
perspectives whatever it is they might
just start to come around and show you a
bit of compassion
yes let's get 60 seconds on the clock
for TK Coleman he's making me go first
because I always steal his
uh so for the first time in history my
own Maxim people can't love you unless
you give them the real you imagine the
following scenario you're raising money
for a really important need and you go
around begging everyone to give you
money and surprisingly everyone is
compassionate and they just shower you
with money but everyone writes it in the
form of a check and so you collect all
these checks you don't take the time to
look at them but you're excited because
people have given you a lot of money and
you go to the bank to cash the check and
they say uh the name on these checks
doesn't match the name on your ID and
you look and you can't cash the check
because it's written in a different name
that is what it's like when you do all
sorts of things to get people to love
you but then you can't cash in on that
experience of love because it's not even
the real you that they love you gave
them some sort of character that you
thought would be easy to deal with but
ultimately they're loving a character
not the real you and you can't really
enjoy love if the real you is isn't
around to enjoy the benefits give them
the real you even if it makes them
uncomfortable yeah CK Coleman
I mean he was like two seconds over but
whatever
it's one of those buzzer beaters that
just looks so good the ref is like it
counts
it's LeBron it counts give me some time
on the clock so
here's what I'll say you know I'll often
say that judgment is a mirror that
reflects the insecurities of the judge
I'd like to append that or update it
amend it with
some new information here
specific to Shauna judgment is a mere
reflecting the preferences of the judge
so quite often when these people were
saying I could never live that
minimalist lifestyle I need my house to
be more cottagey right I need my home to
have more things I need more stuff than
you
now they're judging you and saying you
should have the things that I want as
well
understanding they're simply revealing
their preferences to you it's not a
judgment of your things it's a judgment
of how your life would fit into their
life and as soon as you understand that
you don't have to cling to their
preferences you can even get curious you
can welcome their preferences Ah that's
great for you
but this is great for me yeah welcoming
the preferences that's the compassion
I'm talking about yes like that is
that's exactly how you do it let's move
on to right here right now one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist we'll do that here in a
second but first let's check in with our
patreon live stream from Alabama do you
have a question from the live stream for
us we sure do here's a question from
Georgina how do I let go of excess
possessions like clothes kitchen gadgets
Electronics Etc while I'm unemployed for
a bit and stuck in a survival mentality
oh
first things first
if you need to get employed first before
you can know what you need to let go
that's cool minimalism doesn't come with
a shot clock right there is no rule that
says you've got to make all the
decisions you are ever going to make
about all the stuff that you will ever
get away in the next 30 seconds 30
minutes 30 days or whatever it may be it
sounds like you're in a situation right
now where the number one priority is to
figure out what you're going to do
professionally what your source of
income is going to be and then once you
have those things locked in place you'll
be able to look at your situation and
make a better assessment about what you
can afford to keep and what you can
afford to let go off I would prioritize
them that way um man I uh I almost want
to say like this is the best time to let
go of stuff because if you're unemployed
you're probably uh thinking about
finances I know I was when I got laid
off I was thinking about finances I
started selling my stuff yes like the
stuff that I absolutely knew that like
okay that's that doesn't fit in the you
know the time for me it was the one year
one year rule like that I used in the
last here am I going to use it in the
next year so I can make decisions based
off of you know mostly that ruled or a
few others I use as well
um but uh yeah I mean this might be the
best time for you to get rid of stuff
because you can maybe even earn a little
extra income while you're you're
unemployed this year I've sold more
things than I ever have and all of those
things that I sold
I don't miss them right and so we tell
ourselves this story that I'm Gonna Miss
This it's going to have some
hypothetical value and a hypothetical
future and that future arrives and it's
still a piece of junk that's sitting
there in our house now it is true there
are some things that you may miss if you
let go of them right but also recognize
you're still complete without it even if
you miss it you let it go because it was
getting in the way and if something's
getting in the way that's generally a
good idea to let it go yeah you
literally sold all of your furniture
yeah all little this year I sold all of
my furniture and it was freeing and it
was also in the moment it was terrifying
because it was like oh this is a part of
me this is my identity this is who I am
yeah but of course I realized no this
isn't me these are things that I get
value from I have gotten value from but
I'm not going to hold on to them I'm not
going to cling to them I'm not going to
drag them into my future yeah I'm going
to start with that clean slate yeah did
you hear him talk about him selling his
furniture so his landlord went into his
place and was like oh my God like I had
no idea that this place could be so
beautiful and it was because of the way
he decorated what he's like who's your
decorator and Josh is like me he's like
man he's like can I buy all of this off
of you and Josh is like uh let me put a
list together a price list together and
yeah sure we could talk about that and
he ended up selling like pretty much all
of his furniture yeah quite literally
couch beds everything that's amazing
starting with that clean slate I'll tell
you it was a beautiful gift that clean
slate as difficult as it was
it was really freeing because even I as
one of the minimalists has this desire
to hold on right I'm okay with holding
on I'm holding on too tightly that's
when we get dragged real quick for right
here right now here's one thing going on
in the life of the minimalist by the way
we'll check back in with our patreon
live stream on the private podcast but
Ryan since this is our 12 year
anniversary
it's worth noting that it all started
with this little blog
called the minimalists.com yeah on
December 14th 2010 we went live with the
minimalists.com it was this little blog
and it took us a few months to Cobble
this thing together and it was so
beautiful because it was so simple the
bones were the beauty and even today the
blog still looks fundamentally the same
pretty much as it did yeah slightly
different but it looks pretty much the
same as it was 12 years ago and people
show up and say why how do you get it to
be so beautiful that's because of it's
so simple there aren't advertisements
there aren't banner ads there aren't
sidebar things there aren't all there
isn't all of us busyness that distracts
you it gets to the essence of what we're
trying to communicate and that blog
which we started in 2010 so in 20 2009
Ryan and I or I started simplifying
first my mother died my marriage agenda
I started simplifying I was writing
about my mom's death and and the
marriage ending I was writing fiction at
the time and and I was simplifying I
started feeling Freer and happier and
lighter and then eventually after eight
months of simplifying I got rid of 90 of
my stuff TK and
in that process Ryan came to me and he
said you know why the hell are you so
happy lately he's like you're not
supposed to be happy you're you're you
know this is terrible you are working 80
hours a week your marriage ended and and
your life is supposed to be in shambles
right now right
and I told him about this thing called
minimalism and he's you know super
extreme
um a very American attitude and he's
like I need to simplify right now he's
like how'd you do it I'm like well I
took eight months and I slowly
considered he's like yeah whatever screw
that lame yeah and so we came with this
idea of the packing party which folks
saw in our last Netflix film lessons now
and he just boxed up everything as if he
were moving and unpacked everything that
he needed over the next 21 days that was
the beginning of the minimalists.com was
that 21 day packing party and so we
started a website we didn't know it was
called a Blog at the time and I was
writing essays because that's what I was
familiar with I wasn't really familiar
with blog posts and the terminology and
so we figured out how to build a website
and I realized how simple it could be
even though at first it was really
difficult and so 12 or 11 years ago Ryan
and I we wrote
a blog post called how to start a
successful blog today and we just
updated it this month it's called how to
start a successful blog in 2023 and it's
literally our step-by-step process
because the blog that we started in 2010
is still the backbone of everything that
we do and we can attribute everything
that we've done since then to starting
that blog Ryan and I have published four
best-selling books together we've been
on 10 speaking tours book tours podcast
tours we started a podcast and
eventually brought TK on board and
Mallory and Jordan no more Professor
Sean and podcast Sean and Danny unknown
and Emma The Immigrant and the rest of
our team and we brought them here all
because this blog started and people
started getting value from it I remember
that first month when people showed up
we had 52 readers that first month and
that's really unimpressive to the
average person but for me I spent my
entire 20s TK getting rejection letters
from Agents and Publishers everyone who
read my writing was saying no
but then when Ryan came to me with this
idea like hey Josh you've been writing
for a while maybe we could write about
this whole minimalism thing we've been
trying out and I was like okay we'll
give it a shot finally someone was
saying yes 52 people said yes to my
writing and the 52 turned into 500 turn
into 5 000 turn into 5 million people
eventually and so millions of people
have read what we've done and it all
started with that blog so if you are
interested in starting your own website
or blog because you want a creative
Outlet to express yourself to
communicate with an audience well we
have that recipe it's a step-by-step
recipe you can start a blog in less than
an hour and start writing right away
without anything Superfluous you have to
spend the months that Ryan and I did if
just fumbling around together yeah
cobbling together HTML I wish we had
this resource that we had when we
started our blood because he called me
up like after a week of this idea of
starting a website and he was like I
can't do it man he's I I mean I don't
know how to code like I really I've
tried it's like learning a new language
he's like I don't think we can do this
and I'm like okay like no pressure you
know but then he had come across like
some tools that
um coders already had out there for us
and uh he was able to use those and it
made it so much more simple but we could
have avoided a lot of pain if we had
like a guide like we have right now on
our website in fact so many people
started coming to us and they're like
hey how did you start your blog that's
why I wrote the original post and I've
updated it a bunch since then in fact I
just updated it this week with a bunch
of questions that people have asked over
the course of this last year they're
asking questions about is blogging dead
or how do I uh make my blog more
successful how I reach an audience and
so all of these questions that people
have asked I just said okay great
instead of me just answering people
one-on-one I update this blog post so
you can start a blog in less than an
hour but also there's a bunch of
questions if you have questions about
communicating with your creativity then
all those questions are answered there
at the minimalists.com blog you can
check that out right now also if you're
considering our private podcast
you know you get a month free right now
if you sign up for a year uh over on
patreon patreon.com the minimalists I
will say this this is the only podcast
worth paying for because we don't do any
advertisements although I really on
April 1st I on our website I want to do
a bunch of banners and like pop-up ads
but like of you know just uh fake
companies you know Mountain Dew you know
like just like really obviously fake ads
anyway we could do Christmas ads like
promote holiday songs holiday characters
this week promoting elf so if you're
considering our private podcast I'll ask
you this give it a month we think that
you're really going to enjoy it every
Monday we give you a maximal dose of
minimalism two to three hours for those
maximal episodes you can do the audio
version you can do the video version and
also we have a true fan tier our top
tier over on patreon you get all of our
monthly events so you have whole Archive
of live events that we've done all the
way back over the years so Ryan and I
have done 10 tours a lot of those are
filmed or the audio version is out there
and if you're one of our thousand true
fans on patreon you have access to not
just our current Live Events every time
every month we put out a new live event
on patreon but all the archives of our
Live Events as well no matter what tier
of support you uh you subscribe to you
also get access to all of our archives
our podcast archives to go all the way
back to 2015 you get access to all of
the archives I mean it's more minimalism
than you can choose so you'll go back in
there you'll find the things that really
resonate with you you don't have to
listen in chronological order but find
the things that resonate there's so many
archives you've got the quarantine
conversations we did during the pandemic
with 50 different thinkers and musicians
and podcasters and friends of ours who
have never done a podcast cast ever and
we just had these great conversations
while we were all stuck in our homes
there's so much over there on patreon I
would encourage you to check it out if
you're one of those thousand true fans
by the way last time I checked there
were 19 slots available because we
capped that one tier at a thousand true
fans Kevin Kelly's idea of the Thousand
true fans yeah and so at the moment as
of this recording there are 19 spots
left if you are interested all right
before we get to our listener tips today
coming up on the maximal episode this
week we have a million more questions
from callers social media and the live
stream we have a private minimalist home
tour we're taking a detour for this one
Ryan we are going way back down memory
lane I have some rare photos of our very
first tour in 2011 and basically I have
these photos so we can make fun of your
shorts
uh we have our impulse purchases segment
coming up we of course have TK's tweet
of the week and a brand new segment from
Ryan it's called tossing Ryan's word
salad
we've got an outstanding added value
segment for you as well it's a book a
poem and an argument and much more of
less including all of our part podcast
archives if you're interested
patreon.com
the minimalists try it out for a month
you'll be glad you did malabama what
else you got for us here's a minimalist
Insight from one of our listeners hello
this is lighted from Brazil and I would
like to share my experience with living
Facebook I once had 5 000 Facebook
friends because I believed this would
bring membar business it did not these
people were collecting me like one more
pin for the Pinterest board of friends
as was I so I started to unfriend them
one by one and once I got to only people
I actually knew I still had over 400
friends there's no way that keeping in
touch with 400 people would add value to
my life so I decided to ignore the
potential backlash and then friend until
I was down to close friends only and
guess what there was Zero backlash
because these people did not actually
care about me as much as I did not
actually care about them the next step
seemed so obvious to me all my close
friends have my number so why not limit
these interactions to actual
conversations and delete Facebook all
together it's been over a year and I
never looked back
all right y'all that's our minimal
episode for today we'll see you on
patreon for the full three hour maximal
edition of episode 371 if you leave here
today with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
[Music]
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it foreign